et c'est quoi ça temps mais c'est une
météorite
bah oui oui bah oui c'est une météorite
ça se voit que cédric c'est au ritz
ils se foutent quoi dans mon lit quoi
non mais c'est le chien ça tu sais il
prend toujours des trucs comme ça et à
des endroits ces météorites
oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
il ya un seul truc que j'aime autant que
les feuilles de vigne et les chansons de
bernard minet en vitesse x 2 c les
météorites
outre leur ressemblance frappante avec
des petits kaka de l'espace elles sont
surtout des témoins de l'histoire avec
un grand h
l'une d'elles était même aux premières
loges quand les dinosaures non aviaires
son mourut bas vu que les uns peut
aiguiller quoi vous rappeler de cette
époque enfin vous peut-être pas mais
votre maman sans doute c'était à 66
millions d'années c'est la crise la
vraie pas celle qui ébranle les traders
et les classes moyennes dans celle qui
terrasse 75% des espèces sur terre et on
sait même pas si elles ont eu le temps
de sécuriser leurs placements avant de
passer l'armé à gauche c'est peut-être
ça le plus triste
le scénario catastrophe le voici
rodrigues est une fat météorite qui pèse
au moins 1000 milliards de tonnes et
mesure 11 à 80 km de diamètre c'est pas
rien puisque c'est la distance entre
fougères et peint rodrigues donc un
pacte la terre dans le golfe du mexique
sans avoir le temps de crier timber elle
creuse un critère de plus de 20
kilomètres de profondeur le cratère de
chicxulub elle déclenché un tsunami qui
se propage dans tous les océans du globe
projette dans l'atmosphère des nuages de
poussière et une pluie de cailloux comme
un fléau biblique est là pour le vivant
bas ça sent le sapin
les chercheurs ont même retrouvé dans
les branchies de poissons fossiles des
petites billes de verre qu'ils ont
respiré avant de mourir cbe c'est ce
qu'on appelle des microtechniques
ce sont des éclats de roches terrestres
qui sont créées par l'impact de la
météorite
sous le choc les éclats fonde
instantanément ils sont propulsés dans
l'air il refroidit ce en plein vol et
sans même voir le temps de bien
l'arranger leurs atomes du coup ça donne
des petites gouttes de verre en fait les
derniers instants des dinosaures
ressembler probablement à ça imagine un
ciel constellé de minuscule goutte de
verre incandescente comme au temps des
toiles filantes qui vont se fourrer
directement dans leurs naseaux et les
cramé de l'intérieur et de l'extérieur
aussi puisque la température ambiante
avoisiner très vite celle d'un four à
pizza heureusement pour nous des
météorites aussi grosse que l'ego de
monter ça ne court pas les rues
on estime qu'en moyenne il y en a une
tous les 100 millions d'années en
moyenne un ca veut pas dire qu'on passe
en ont plafonné une dent 40 millions
d'années il peut en avoir deux d'un coup
et puis plus rien pendant un bail c'est
la joie des statistiques cela dit
heureusement que c'est rare parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a toujours pas de
moyens pour dévier un astéroïde un peu
trop affectueux
mais du coup les stéroïdes et les
météorites
c'est pas pareil alors dans l'espace
c'est un astéroïde quand sa trace
atmosphère c'est un météore et sur terre
si oui on sait sur terre une météorite
n'empêche vous aimez bien vous prendre
la tête
vous n'auriez pas pu appeler ça moi je
sais pas un caillou spatiale est
d'ailleurs un ou une astéroïde 1 en de
branquignols semaines ce planning de
l'espace que non mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes pas du tout le match fini que
c'est pas du tout ça c'est quand sûrs
mais revenons-en à nos météorite celles
qui dominent le paysage ce sont des
poussières des grains de moins de 2 mm
de diamètre qui nous font des jolies
petites étoiles filantes quand elles
entrent dans l'atmosphère qui nous
permettent de faire des voeux comme être
heureux ou voir une étoile filante
on estime que plus de 99% des cailloux
céleste eux disparaissent complètement
en traversant notre atmosphère où les
frottements avec l'air les grilles
joyeusement mais il ne parvient quand
même cinq mille tonnes de poussée avec
stratégistre au sol chaque année
également 5000 météorite assez balèze 1
de la taille d'un ballon de handball
et si en plus on a la chance de les voir
tomber du ciel rebelles aux louanges ça
c'est la référence pour les plus de 60
ans
comme m c'est vraiment un moment magique
enfin sofiane nous tombe dessus
d'ailleurs on n'y a pas toujours cru à
ces météorites aujourd'hui ça nous
paraît évident mais jusqu'au 19ème
siècle les savants occidentaux regardais
les pécores à leur disais ouais des
pierres qui tombent du ciel puis quoi
encore des pluies de bic est un magazine
féminin sans promotion des
pseudosciences ne la fait pas à moi les
extraterrestres l'aca a déjà pas marcher
dans indiana jones ça marchera pas mieux
pour vous non moi je dis ça doit être un
bon gros coup de vent qui les aura
soulevé ou alors c'est juste des pierres
volcaniques ou ou des pierres de foudre
non mais ils sont cuits au centre
commercial de cela deux pôles explique
atchoum quoi je parlais fulgure it c'est
quand la foudre tombe sur une roche et
qu'elle a fait fondre
oui bah comme mon cerveau quand je vous
écoute pour vous dire à quel point on
n'y croyez pas en 1492 une énorme
météorite tombe en alsace heinz à nsn
merci les villageois en prélève des
bouts ils s'en font des talismans puis
la météorite est récupéré et placé dans
l'église
on lui prête même un présage comme quoi
il aurait prophétisé qui gagnerait une
bataille de l'époque c'est un peu comme
un paul le poulpe de l'espace et puis
quelques érudits mettent leur nez
paracelse philosophe et médecin a conclu
que la pierre était identique à la
matière s
et lui de renvoyer les habitants
d'ensisheim à leurs superstitions et à
leur église
un peu moins de deux siècles plus tard
goethe de passage dans le coin a lui
aussi examiné le caillou céleste il
s'est moqué de la crédulité des humains
qui imaginait voir tomber des pierres
dans leurs champs il aura donc fallu
attendre 1794 pour que le physicien
allemand ernst schladming comme ça se
prononce propose pour la première fois
que les pierres tombées du ciel existe
bel et bien qu'elles ont une origine
extraterrestre et qu'elles peuvent nous
apprendre deux trois petits trucs sur
les autres mondes c'était une véritable
rupture épistémologique à l'époque sa
thèse n'a pas eu un succès fou tout de
suite mais c'est au début des années
1800 après avoir enquêté méthodiquement
autour de la chute d'une météorite en
normandie que la communauté scientifique
a dit aux paysans bah en fait vous aviez
raison autant pour nous allez sans
rancune mais tout le monde ne croyait
pas pas aux météorites
certains y croyait comme al aqsa gore de
classe domaine cette antique philosophe
grec présocratiques s'appelle une
insulte pensait que les météorites
étaient des pierres détaché du soleil
alors que tout le monde considérait que
les astres étaient des dieux et ben lui
il pensait que c'était des pierres
incandescentes
il disait même que celle du soleil était
plus grande que le péloponnèse ce qu'on
appelle avoir du flair bref trêve de
pierres incandescentes
non seulement ces cailloux de l'espace
ont pu assister à nos chamailleries
scientifique mais en plus ils ont
contribué au développement de nos
civilisations et pour ça je vous emmène
dans un tombeau
ce tombeau ne sera pas votre tombeau car
si celui de toutankhamon en 1926 on a
découvert dans le cercueil du pharaon
une dague bien particulière puisque on
apprendra quatre-vingt dix ans plus tard
que salam a été forgée dans un métal
extraterrestre issu d'une météorite
est-ce qu'il faut y voir un symbole
particulier pour autant bas pas sûr à
l'époque les météorites c'était surtout
le seul minerai de fer disponible
pratiquement un minerai est extrêmement
rare et donc très très très précieux
exploiter dès la préhistoire
on pense même que les tous premiers
objets en fer étaient fabriqués à partir
de métal météoritique et ce minerai il a
été utilisé depuis y ait au tibet en
chine en syrie en mésopotamie et même de
façon beaucoup plus contemporaine par
les inuits au nord du groenland il avait
pas assez de bois pour inventer la
métallurgie du coup bah ils ont fabriqué
leurs outils et leurs harpon en
utilisant des fragments de la météorite
de capitaux requis serait tombé il ya
plusieurs milliers d'années dans la
région d'un arm avatar bat à donc on
peut presque dire que l'âge du fer des
inuits est d'origine extraterrestre
enfin ça c'était jusqu'en 1894 jusqu'à
ce que l'explorateur américain robert
peary se fasse rencarder sur l'endroit
où étaient ces météorites
le mec a rien trouvé de mieux que de
rafler les fragments et
ramener son butin aux états unis et les
a revendues au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de new york où ils sont encore
visibles aujourd'hui et on est sûr que
c'est une météorite du coup mais
totalement de ces météorites je les ai
vus tomber
ouais ben ça c'est un bon indice en
général sinon certains types de
météorites sont assez dense parce
qu'elles sont riches en métal
ensuite c'est souvent foncé lisse et
doux au toucher comme la part d'un
crédit et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle sa
croûte de fusion elle se crée quand la
pierre s'échauffent en traversant
l'atmosphère
ensuite si on avait de quoi l'ouvrir on
pourrait regarder s'il ya des grumeaux à
l'intérieur c'est pas le cas pour tout
un mais la plupart en ont en fait c'est
des gouttes de magma qui ont cristallisé
en apesanteur dans l'espace on les
appelle des contres du coup on en fait
quoi de la météorite laon la fois un
musée où florence tu fais quoi avec un
adieu ni toi un quoi non mais c'est une
météorite
et pourquoi ya une finale au bout alors
ah non mais ça c'est moi j'ai voulu en
faire un collier du coup on voulait
demander cette météorite la font la file
un musée où on peut la garder
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'en
france ça part vraiment de loi qui va
protéger la météorite
quant à des décisions de justice qui
datent du 19e siècle à peu près et bad
et fois aiguisé basse est la propriété
de la personne qui avait le terrain
c'est des fois c'est la propriété de la
personne qui l'a découvert mais en fait
tu n'as aucune mention à aucun moment de
l'aspect scientifique qui peut y avoir
et même en 2014 tu avais une décision de
justice qui en parler et en fait c'était
revenu à personne qui avait découvert la
météorite
mais on sait pas du tout ce qu'il en
faisait ensuite s'il le donner à un
musée ou quoi donc en 2014 pas tenir
compte de l'aspect scientifique que peut
avoir une météorite
on a un peu la bourgogne mais c'est pas
le cas partout parce que tu as les pays
qui vont obliger à la remettre par
exemple à l'état donc donc là au musée
tout ça donc là c'est le cas de l'inde
tu as des pays qui vont prévoir une
compensation financière en échange parce
que ça peut représenter beaucoup
d'argent donc danemark suisse et tout ça
et d'autres pays qui vont dire bah c'est
la propriété de la personne qui l'a
découvert donc ça c'est le cas du
royaume-uni de la russie des états unis
par exemple
c'est les états unis ça me fait penser
c'est la même chose pour les les
fossiles donc gens s'y retrouvent un
fossile de dinosaure dans ton jardin aux
états unis tu peux le garder en tête
c'est que dans les soixante et soixante
dix on a fait des traités par rapport à
l'espace est la lune et tout ça et on a
mis un principe de non appropriation
en fait c'est un peu le patrimoine
commun de l'humanité si tu veux et saufs
qui a une exception pour les météorites
précisément chez pierre le truc c'est
dit ne s'applique pas aux matière
extraterrestre qui atteignent la surface
de la terre par des moyens naturels
je sais que je me suis appuyé sur un
rapport celui de dellys bleury et du
projet vj ciel en fête qui forme des
gens pour qu'ils puissent reconnaître
les météorites et du coup les ramener à
des musées sans les abîmer où vont les
choses
ça fait partie des programmes de
sciences participatives du muséum 10 ans
messieurs ouais ouais ouais carrément et
du coup c'est super intéressant ils ont
même fait une chartre des cueilleurs de
météorites plus trop mignon
[Musique]
si on demande à notre météorite a lui eu
des mots
la réponse sera probablement entre mars
et jupiter dans la ceinture d'astéroïdes
principal là bas les cailloux de
l'espace aime bien se collisionner pour
le fan comme des vrais bonhomme et ce
faisant ils sont des petits peeling
réciproque
on a donc des petites miettes
d'astéroïdes leurs peaux mortes qu'il
vole est joyeusement dans l'espace et
qui saupoudre parfois les autres corps
du système solaire comme des pellicules
divine choix je m'arrêter là avec cette
métaphore bref l'immense majorité de nos
météorites proviennent d'astéroïdes pour
les autres ça peut être des bouts de
mars ou de la lune qui ont été arrachés
lors d'un impact avec un gros astéroïde
et qui nous arrive directement par colis
postal et même s'ils représentent que
moins d'un pour cent de toutes les
météorites qu'on trouve sur terre ces
morceaux de lune ou de mars sont hyper
utiles aux scientifiques parce qu'ils
leur permettent d'étudier le sol de ces
corps sans même avoir à y poser le pied
ce qui est rigolo c'est qu'en 2019
on a trouvé une météorite terrienne sur
la lune dans un échantillons lunaires
rapportée par les missions apollo
c'est à un petit éclat de granit
incorporé dans une brèche lunaire donc
tout ça pour dire que ça marche dans les
deux sens quoi mais c'est pas tout on
dit à l'instant que les météorites
avaient été témoins de notre histoire ça
ok mais c'est surtout de vrais capsule
temporelle qui nous aident à
reconstituer le scénario de la formation
du système solaire et pour ça il faut
creuser un peu leur chimie parce que non
tous les petits kaka de l'espace ne se
valent pas 8 météorite sur 10 sont des
chondrites pour les puristes cd
péridotite avec du fer métal dedans
c'est elle qui contiennent ces fameuses
pépites de magma ou sahel et chondre
essais chondrites elles sont les mamies
de l'espace
elles se sont formées il ya 4 55
milliards d'années et depuis elles ont
pas bougé d'un iota
les vendeurs de crème anti âge et des
tests voici une expérience amusante à
faire chez vous prenez la terre toute
entière et passez la au mixeur vous
obtiendrez la même chimiques une
chondrite les mêmes éléments dans les
mêmes proportions
ce qu en déduisent les scientifiques
c'est que à l'origine la terre est un
tas de chondrites éparpillés attirés par
la gravité elles se sont agglomérés les
unes aux autres et puis à cause de
l'énergie produite par les collisions et
la radioactivité des éléments contenus
dans les chondrites les roches ont
chauffé chauffer tant et si bien que le
tas de condrette a fondu pour devenir
une boule de magma en apesanteur les
éléments les plus lourds de l'asu vont
migrer vers le centre sous l'effet de la
gravité alors que les autres sont restés
en surface d'où la formation des couches
concentriques de la terre comme des
pollueurs donnions le noyau riches en
fer et en nickel
puis le manteau silicatées autour pour
pas que la planète attrapera et
scénario que je décris là pour la terre
se serait de même pour les autres
planètes rocheuses du système solaire
comme mars et là où ça devient
intéressant c'est qu'on trouve aussi des
météorites riches en fer et en nickel
on les appelle des sidérite et
chimiquement elle ressemble diablement
noyau terrestre en fait celle là elles
sont hyper belle
ces figures géométriques que vous voyez
là c'est ce qu'on appelle des figures de
wittgenstein des figures de william
shatner montée pitié wiedemann chez
d'autres météorites qu'on appelle à
chondrites ressembla à nos gars braunau
basalte nos péridotite c'est un peu
comme si ces météorites venait d'un
corps différenciée comme la terre et que
leurs débris auraient volts et
joyeusement jusqu'à nous dit donc en
fait bas c'est exactement ça si vous
mixez ces météorites ensemble vous
obtiendrez à nouveau une chondrite donc
les chondrites qu'on échantillonne
aujourd'hui c'est les mamans de la terre
de mars est en réalité de tous les corps
rocheux du système solaire puisqu'elles
ont aussi la même chimiques le soleil si
on omet ces gaz parce qu il en contient
pas canini il devrait essayer le charbon
actif
les scientifiques pensent que ces mamies
de l'univers se seraient formés lors de
la condensation de la nébuleuse solaire
sous l'impulsion de décharges
électriques
quand le système solaire est encore
qu'un gros moutons de poussière cosmique
et c'est justement parce que c'est les
plus anciennes roche du système solaire
que les chondrites sont d'aussi bons
témoins de notre histoire
pas seulement l'histoire des hommes ni
celle des sciences ni même celle de la
terre mais bien de tout le système
solaire j'insiste parce que c'est ouf
quand même et à ce titre nous leur
devons le respect même si elle ressemble
à rien je veux dire comparé aux sidéré
tous même aux parasites
ça c'est des météorites de fer avec des
cristaux d'olivier d'incruster elle
correspondrait très précisément à la
limite entre le manteau et le noyau d'un
corps différence mais c'est pas fini
comme si ce n'était pas assez classe
comme ça les météorites détiennent aussi
peut-être la clé de l'énigme de
l'apparition de la vie sur terre
parce que si jamais on arrive à trouver
ne serait-ce que des petites bactéries à
la con sur ces météorites bas ça
pourrait confirmer l'hypothèse de la
panspermie qui dit que la vie sur terre
auraient été apportées depuis l'espace à
l'heure actuelle on n'a encore aucune
preuve de ça il ya bien eu une fausse
alerte à la fin des années 90 quand une
équipe américaine a cru trouver des tout
petits verres fossiles sur une météorite
martienne l'annoncent à d'ailleurs été
faite par le donald trump de l'époque
bill clinton
mais en fait c'était juste des artefacts
analytics ça la fout un peu mal pour les
américains mais à défaut de trouver de
la vie dans les météorites
on y trouve parfois des briques de vie
des molécules complexes comme des acides
aminés ou de l'urée
donc en ce sens les météorites
pourraient avoir apporté certains
ingrédients nécessaires à la vie sur
terre
cela dit on n'est pas beaucoup plus
avancé parce que l'on sait toujours pas
comment passer de cette chimie
prébiotique à la vie par contre c'est
bel et bien de météorites qui nous a
fait découvrir une nouvelle forme de vie
des bactéries nanométrique mille fois
plus petit que l'épaisseur d'un poil de
barbe un crédit elles ont été trouvées
dans la météorite de tataouine tombés en
tunisie en 1931
c'est une à chondrites qui ressemble à
nos péridotite ouanougha bros manque de
bol c'était une contamination terrestre
ces bactéries n'avait rien d' alien en
elle elles ont dû partir à l'assaut du
caillou quand ils mijotait
tranquillement sur terre en attendant
qu'on le découvre n'empêche qu'on savait
pas à l'époque qui pouvaient exister des
bactéries aussi petit sur terre et ça
c'est grâce à une météorite qu'on l'a
découvert et depuis qu'on sait qu'elle
existe on en a trouvé beaucoup d'autres
ailleurs dans de vieilles météorites et
ça dit entre que ces boues merci si vous
aimez les petits kaka de l'espace
n'hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo à la
partager à vous abonner à mettre la
cloche et à nous rejoindre sur le
discorde pour parler de bill clinton
ah c'était clairement une météorite
venez voir à l'ats péter l'invite l'a
carrément non mais c'est pas plutôt toi
qui l'embêté la vitre là parce que quand
on entend depuis ta du vert partout quoi
à tout façon on peut pas les garder
c'est pas moral va t'en va t'en moi je
pour qu'on l'a on va la garder à wim
aussi bon bah voilà 2 voies sur 4
du coup valentine elle pourrait voter
que ça change rien de façon le risque il
est d'accord avec nous dont bas ont la
garde
yes yes yes
[Musique]
si vous avez plein de questions
n'hésitez pas à venir va lui poser en
direct sur twitter parce que j'y serai
là pendant que la vidéo sera diffusée
comme ça on va pouvoir débriefer tout ça
ensemble
et puis regardez des jolies photos de
météorites et est plein de trucs trop
cool allez venez ça va être bien